وفي الاستوديو تنضم لنا المؤخره الهنديه
والمشاركه في مسلسل دبي لينك فرحانه بودي
اهلا بك شكرا على تواجدك معانا في صباح
العربيه نورتينا في الاستديو
[موسيقى]
طيب
انت شخصيا الهدف من مشاركتك في برنامج
التلفزيون
الاصليه
مترجم جمهور واسع عالميه ان يشاهدني كما
اشعر بان رضيع قصه او دون اعبر عنه الكثير
من متابعي وجماهيري لا
يعرفون فرحانه الحقيقيه ما يشاهدونه على
انستجرام او فقط اجزاء بسيطه من حياتي ولا
يعرفون كل شيء عني ولكن اني عبر برنامجه
هذه قصار استطيع ان احكيها والان يعرفوني
بشكل افضل
سطحيه الي كانت بينكم يعني قالوا لنا
مشاكل بسيطه قدامه هموم ومسؤوليات الناس
هل فعلا هاي المشاكل هي المشاكل الحقيقيه
هل هي مشاكل لكم بس لانه اذا هيك يعني يا
ريت نتبادل المشاكل بين بعض ولا بس عشان
اللزوم الشغل
تريقه على الناس
على البرنامج هو حياتنا الحقيقيه ما هو
موجود وما نعيشه ومن يمر به انا ادرك بان
الكثيره يجدون بان هذه الامور سطحيه ولكنه
هنالك من لديه هذه المشاكل بحقه وما
تشاهدونه على البرنامج حقيقي الكثير
يقولون بان كلها مجرد نصوص او غير حقيقيه
كلا هذه هي حياتنا وما كنا نعيشه في تلك
اللحظه
سرحيه والبعض يجدوها ترفيهيه اول بعض
احبها فوق كل واحد حسب ذوقك طيب فرحانه
بعيده عن الصوره الجميله المسلسل بشكل عام
وجودكم فيه لكن البعض انتقد واعتبر انه
المسلسل نجح لكن باثاره الجدل كونوا انه
سطحي وينقل صوره سيئه عن المراه موضوع في
اطار الاستعراض والنميمه
[موسيقى]
الراي الخاصه انا شخصيا
نفسي
الذين احبوا البرنامج واحب وقصتي واحب
حكتني والوالدات
واهتموا بابني لوحدي
وكل واحد بالتاكيد ما يقوله عن البرنامج
من جانبي حصلته على تقديره ايجابي اكثر من
سلبيه وهذا يساعدني واحنا كمان مبسوطين
بوجودك
كمان فرحانه بيقولوا لك انه كثير صور
الشوق الايزي ماني مش انه في اشخاص هذه
حين قصص ملهمه عن جافيه
[موسيقى]
عادي
اتفهم انه في البرنامج
كل واحد لديه اسلوب الحياه هذه ولكن لدينا
العمل ايضا منظهرهم في البرنامج هو كيف
نعيش حياتنا ولكننا عملنا جاهدين الوصول
الى هذه المرحله جدا للوصول الى هذه
المرحله كما قلت هذا البرنامج لا يدور حول
لحياه
تيجي دبي بالعشره افراد وكيف يعيشون
حياتهم في دبي بسهوله
يتصوره البعض مما شاهدوه من البرنامج ربما
يقوم بانه سهل ولكنه ليس كذلك عمل جاهدين
ونتحدث عن نفسي انا اعمل تجاهده جدا
ينتظر ان يقدم دبي لينك همم قصه كيف وصلتم
كيف نجحتم لتكون عبر لغيركم بعيدا عن
الاستعراض يعني كيف تردين على من قال ذلك
[موسيقى]
اه يا سعيد
مع هذا القول ربما كان علينا ان يظهرك كيف
حققنا النجاح
قصص حلوه
السياسه
من الاحداث التي حصلت واغلبها شاهدتموها
على البرنامج ولكنني كنت سعيده جدا انني
تعرفت على نجوم الاخرين بشكل افضل خلال
البرنامج
لما اتحدث مع بعضنا بعض ابدا
فاشعر بان كل شيء حصل للابطال
كلمه انت شخصيا
لمن انتقد البرنامج
الغيره بالتاكيد تجعل التحدث الاشياء
السلبيه انا استخدم هذه
جمل مع الجميع هكذا هي الغيره
ولكن
يتابعه اولا
في افضل او اكثر مشاهده ثلاثه برامج
مشاهده في العالم مسلي جدا ملهم وجراما
وازياء
والكثيره من الالهام لماذا لا يشاهدونها
يجب ان يشاهدونا شكرا
الهنديه والمشاركه في مسلسل